alors c'est un char assiste donc et qui
est très très raciste et qui décident
d'aller contre ces préjugés
donc il dit bon allez je vais à la
mosquée peut-être que c'est pas comme je
pense peut-être que voilà il dit je vais
à la mosquée d'où qui va à la mosquée le
vendredi et oui ça soit avec vous il
enlève ses chaussures elle est comment
s'ils cessent le discours de l'imam
commence et où il se sent un petit peu
quand même apaisé spirituellement est
pas mal tous les mêmes marche dans les
rangs comme celle va le voir et lui mais
armand sur le front comme ça et lui dit
tu vas marché alors à city mais attendez
je comprends pas je vais pas le problème
de motricité moi je marchais je
comprends pas bref la prière commence la
prière finie il sort et ils voient qu'on
lui a volé sa voiture
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je prends l'avion allait il va à new
york et dans l'est dans l'avion il sur
la france et y voit une petite pancarte
où est dit ici on est à même de vous
apprendre l'anglais donc le belge
appelle l'hôtel si ça m'intéresse il dit
je vais à new york pour le business et
je parle pas l'anglais il dit comment ça
marche seule vidéo écoutez c'est rien de
très exhaustif mais vous payez 7 $ vous
avez un petit casque pc les bases de
langage et du vin de pays
mais pendant sept heures le mec ne bouge
pas avec le casque qui né comme ça ils
bougent pas il y en a qui regardent des
films d'autres qui dorment utilise lui
bouge pas avec le casque
l'avion atterrit à kennedy airport le
belge pose le casque va la douane le
douanier le reçoit lui fait martine
taudis claire et réponses
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est en fin de nuit et j'entends des
bruits dans la chambre de ses parents il
descend pige à 22 cents ils en trouvent
là la porte de la chambre de ses bancs
et voit sa maman qui chevauche son son
papa samba il est allongé sur le dos
tout nu
elle est toute nue aussi y'a que vost sa
niche on qui se barre dans tous les cra
ferme-la bord il remonte dans sa chambre
et lendemain matin il dit maman faut que
je te dise un truc jeu je crois que j'ai
fait un truc pas bien c'est n'ai vu que
c'était fait mon petit jérôme bats
indigents a entendu du bruit de votre
chambre et je suis venu regarder à sa
mère a dit oui c'est pas terrible ça
c'est vrai alors dit à maman qu'est ce
que tu as vu et bien dit j'ai vu que
t'étais tout nu un évident tu sautes est
comme ça sans leur ventre à papa qui
était tenue au cias a dit oui oui oui
bon c'est vrai gens que tu es bien vu tu
es assez grands maintenant maman va
t'expliquer tu as remarqué que papa il
avait un peu un gros ventre alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait maman
à lui me fait mal saute sur le ventre
popa pour essayer de le dire un petit
garçon m'a dit maman ça marchera jamais
ton truc
banier pour que je vous dise ah bah dis
parce que tous les matins la baume leur
gonfle
[Applaudissements]
d'où l'intérêt mais je pense qu'on a la
garde et cela parce que c'est ma
classique style classique label
bruxellois qui veut voir son copain et
qui lui dit qu'est ce qu'on fait ce week
end je pense sert à rien d'aller en
boîte encore on attrape jamais rien tous
les deux ça marche pas il on va aller à
paris et pourquoi il dit à paris on
baise syllabes aurait dit oui et diers
paris quand tu prends le train tu baises
quand arrive à la gare tu baises quand
tu vends restaurant tu baises à quoi tu
vas en boîte de nuit du bez utah sur
deux se dit que certains diront pas à
paris sont dans le tgv dispense pas
grand chose dit attends je te dis qu'on
va baiser dit oui mais il se passe rien
média temps ça arrive à la gare et dean
sérieux placez dans le train se passe
rien à lagarrigue y attend
le restaurant restaurant il se passe
rien non plus ils vont en boîte à 80 du
matin mais glissant suffit maintenant on
rentre c'est des conneries 1
hédi ben non attends 20 des zi nord
c'est des conneries on rentre il rentre
le lendemain ils prennent le tgv retour
ai dit tu te rends compte on apprit
frein on n'a pas baisé la gare on n'a
pas baissé le restaurant on n'a pas
baissé la boîte de nuit non plus il dit
pourtant c'est sûr normalement baisse
tout le temps il y qui t'a dit ça ma
soeur
[Rires]
alors vas-y mais que le douanier en
quattro et 105 bagnole ou teddy dit ce
n'est pas réglementaire 7 5 dans une
quattro vous ai dit c'est une blague ou
quoi
c'est une voiture pour cinq places
qu'est ce que vous faites chier
appelez moi être supérieur aurait dit je
ne peux pas les t'occuper avec les deux
mecs dans la uno la halle et je ne me
dis quand même pas ça ne pas grave on se
défendra la coupe du monde de foot
rappelle que renault est au téléphone à
son pote qui se téléphone tous les deux
trois jours et il appelle et là il ya
une petite voix qui décroche et les
bienfaits à sétois benjamin ton papa est
là oui mais il est occupé à bon ben ça
c'est l'impasse notamment alors dansez
pas possible parce qu'elle est occupée
ah bon mais tonton ton grand frère la
non charles
oui mais lui est occupé bon ma tante une
voix cassée
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya d'autres
gens oui il ya des pompiers et pompiers
chez toi tu tu peux me passer un bon
pied non c'est pas possible parce qu'ils
sont occupés à notre gastronomie à
d'autres gens oui il ya des policiers
tuent policiers les pompiers chez toi et
pas soit un policier
non c'est pas possible parce que lié au
public qu'est ce qu'ils font il me
cherche
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que j'ai des mafias ou du
canoë sénateurs canoë à ces deux styles
complètement différents canaux et ses
trois mecs qui se baladent dans la
jungle il tombe sur une tribu
complètement sauvage qui les attrape qui
les attache et que dit donc très simple
soit vous faites un voeu et on n'arrive
pas à le réaliser
vous vivez si on arrive à le réaliser on
écoute votre peau et on fait des canoës
avec quand il évoquait le premier dit je
voudrais faudrait que tu arrives à aller
chez ton coude
c'est impossible à faire humainement
c'est impossible mais là tu as un mec
qui sort une langue de 70 cm il se
laisse le kun toi et cotisent iba je
voudrais que toutes les guerres
s'arrêtent et mais qui ils leur montrent
un téléphone il ya une news qui vient de
tomber il n'y a plus aucune guerre dans
le monde entier donc pareil ils prennent
sa peau et le mettre sur un canot et ce
afin canaux est le troisième c'est un
peu une car tu vois hélas ai dit moi je
veux une fourchette
t'as pas vu ce qu'ils ont demandé les
autres questionnements d'une fourchette
on va te la bonne fourchette jackass moi
pas la tête de noix une fourchette tient
la fourchette qui prend la fourchette
fait mon canoë ça le matin
[Applaudissements]
chantal ladesou à l'hôtel choisi alors
elle fait le tchèque at elle dit commun
je vous dois et le concierge et 10 800
euros là dessus a dit pardon et 10 800
euros mais la malade souid fait mais je
chante à le dire pardon mais ça ne vaut
pas sa 800 euros il est mais ici ça vaut
ça va l'amener à dessous vous êtes dans
un quatre étoiles et dit oui mais moi je
suis en tournée je suis venu j'ai dormi
je repars savoir 300 pas plus non madame
là dessous il ya des prix on n'était pas
assez et c'est comme ça divine piscine
et bains fallait y aller il va un sauna
fallait y aller il y avait une salle de
gym fallait y aller il y avait un bar
gratuit il fallait y aller chantal
dégoûter les bloquer
vous avez sous les jeux vous paye et
jette 300 euros et et j'ai déduit 500
euros pour lady peep
mais qui dit commencer à lady peep mais
personne n'est venu se faire sucer dans
votre chambre madame late show et 18
mois
elle dit que j'étais là toute l'année il
fallait y aller
installation on a bien entendu moi mon
jules tlc suit la bouche à chery hawtai
oui oui c'est un mec qui rentre dans un
bar a complètement éclaté à gauche chez
les fans et regarde le mec de droite cds
merde là y'a un mec qui se lève et du
mais moi je suis pas une mère c'est un
mec qui a très envie d'avoir un
perroquet meira jours donc y faire
toujours sur des perroquets oui à perdre
et un jour il va donc chez l'oiselier où
il rentre il est pas sûr vraiment mais
bon il y va et dans un tout petit coin
il ya un petit perroquet comme ça il est
touché le mac il avance et il lui dira
fait très longtemps que j'ai envie
d'avoir un perroquet mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive tu as pas de pâte en le
perroquet dit non non mais comment tu
tiens sur ton perchoir il dit bah j'ai
un petit zizi alors je m'accroche parce
que je suis né comme ça je suis né sans
pattes mais avec mes plumes elle le
cache donc c'est pour ça que tu ne vois
pas un indien et tu peux tu peux tenir
une conversation
oui je suis très intelligent très
cultivé je peux même c'est plein de
choses un chemin cinq langues je peux
parler religion philosophie politique le
mec il est emballé le perroquet coûte 14
mille euros le mec qui craque
il achète le perroquet il rentre chez
lui ça se passe très bien pendant
quelques semaines et un soir il rentre
du boulot et le perroquet t-il lui dit
fille j'ai un truc à dire mais je ne
sais pas si je devrais alors ils disent
ici c'est 6 10 mois et page et où tu
t'es vu quoi ta femme avec le facteur 18
ce qu'elle a fait et ma femme avec le
facteur quoi y'a quoi
adiba ce matin le facteur il a sonné et
ta femme l'a ouvert avec une petite
nuisette transparente
d'accord d'accord mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé après et bah après ben il
l'a embrassée quoi mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé après je dis bah il a
commencé à lutter graf et sa nuisette et
puis il a commencé à la caresser comme
ça d'abord il lui a caressé les seins
et après qu'est ce qui s'est passé a le
ventre et puis le bas ventre il dit mais
après que ce qu'ils ont fait pj mais je
sais pas parce que j'ai commencé abordé
puisque tous
[Applaudissements]
c'est un père de famille qui cuisine du
lapin et donc il sert à ses enfants une
assiette de deux lapins voilà mais il
sait que les enfants aiment pas trop a
pas trop ça donc ils décident de ne pas
dire ce que c'est vraiment et la petite
et elle mange à radio monte un c'est
trop bon et tout c'est quoi voit pas
excusé c'est quoi et bah ma chérie je
peux pas dire mais je suis indices ta
mère m'appelle souvent comme ça ait
l'air au crash tous et recrache médias
son frère mange pas mange pas c'est un
trou du cul
[Applaudissements]